[Music]
to one esteemed with the gifts of divine
grace and writing in Christ to rimbor to
the honored elder rat Ramona's screeds
him and the Lord Jesus Christ
everlasting after you were informed of
our request you wrote to us about these
things you were able to learn concerning
the nature of the cynic of Harley and
you pleased me more than a little indeed
I'm going to revise very little of what
you claimed about them but you will know
that by no means did I come to this
sentiment out of the torpor of
carelessness but that I was in fact
uncertain of what was not attested by
the presence of an informer but now a
brother soul Ward is coming to us and
will return to you and given this
opportunity we were anxious to briefly
disclose what we thought concerning your
investigation for you are asking what
you ought to think of this innaka folly
namely whether they were descended from
Adam's stock or if they have the souls
of beasts this question can be briefly
settled as follows if we were to
consider the kind of people there are it
should seem obvious that there had been
descended from the offspring of the
first humans and of course it is
impossible to suppose that a person came
from some other origin then through the
means of the earliest ancestors if we
ponder about the species of beasts named
as such by humans by their nature they
don't communicate that meanwhile with
this knowledge if we were indeed
satisfied with our supposition which is
clearly held by the learning Church
ministers then there the sanaka folly
should be considered closer to beasts
than humans if in fact they have a
canine head shape and bark like dogs it
shows there are not humans but are
similar to beasts
mmm-hmm next a human head is round and
placed on top so he can behold the
heavens whereas the dog's head is oblong
and drawn out in a snout so he looks to
the ground and humans talk but but dogs
in fact bark truly from these letters
you kindly sent us while they studiously
report the nature of this sanaka folly
they indicate several things which seem
to agree that they have the reasoning
mind of a human rather than the
sensibilities of a beast evidently they
uphold the laws of their society they
are said to live together in houses they
practice agriculture they harvest crops
they show that they respect customs
which are not beastly by clothing
themselves with human-like modesty and
this is evidence for their sense of
shame they don't just use hides for
garments but but you even wrote that
they have cloth now in a way all these
things seem to testify that a rational
mind is present within them for since a
civil society may be described as the
unification of degenerate people equally
under the same law and since these
sanaka far they are said to live
together with each other in communal
houses I believe the distinguishing
factor of civility it fits in helpfully
with such creatures and if in fact they
form a crowd when they gather together
they can only live together under some
kind of lawful agreement indeed where
some type of law is preserved it is also
held together with the unanimous
agreement of wills and any sort of law
cannot exist where it isn't decreed by
collective consent certainly laws can
neither be set in place nor ever
preserved without some kind of moral
instruction truly now you will letter
shows that they cultivate fields
plough the earth and sow seeds in the
countryside to gain profit and that they
are skilled in craft these traits would
be completely unknown if there's a knock
of har they were not endowed with the
reasoning mind to support them and as a
matter of fact it is reasonable to look
for the purpose of a single action where
there is a purpose what is it that makes
the soil fertile why did it yield an
abundance of seed without the
agricultural knowledge of these things
could never be cultivated moreover they
have the diligence of a rational mind to
know how to make clothing from either
hide or wool or linen before they could
not have obtained these things without
some kind of workmanship and the
knowledge of craft is only bestowed upon
a rational mind to clothe themselves in
shame is a sign of Honor which is not
sought for unless they can judge in
their mind a difference between disgrace
and decency and surely no one can blush
about in modesty unless they happen to
have some concept of decency now nobody
except someone who lacks reason would
deny that these things are all
characteristic of a rational mind on
this subject when you say that there
seems to be other things among the
sanaka farley you give evidence that a
rational mind really is present in them
truly man is distinguished from the
beasts only by his rationality people
seem to be better at reasoning than
animals the published account of the
martyr st. Christopher seems to
adequately support this understanding
now as it was read there he is thought
to have come from this race of people
and he fully committed both his life and
martyrdom to radiant virtues Cortese
believed that he was divinely influenced
to be baptized with the help of a cloud
pouring all over Emma as evidenced by
his
out additionally many things are being
reported with spreading fame things
which seem to suggest that these race of
people is in command of rational thought
Isadora said that in his notes when he
was talking about the varieties of
monsters which originated from the human
race here in the book of etymologies and
just as there are monstrous individuals
within the clans of people so there are
monstrous clans within the great human
race the Giants the sanaka Farley the
Cyclops etc etc in saying this he
clearly showed did he believe the Seneca
Farley had originated from the offspring
of the first man for just as in the
separate clans certain tribes seemed to
be born against the laws of nature for
example the 2-headed the Tremonti the
the dwarfs the hamara Deitz or androgyny
sir and many more besides
however these monsters don't arise
against the laws of nature but they come
about in a certain way with their own
peculiar disposition since the natural
law is an arrangement of God in the same
way also these marvelous monsters seem
to introduce a monstrous branch to the
natural lineage of the entire human race
monsters who were mentioned above and
many more besides and which take a long
time to list
the the pygmies and the back-to-front
the form of which is said to stand only
a cubit in height and it is said the
ladders feet had turned around behind
their legs and that they have eight toes
in each foot the horse hoof two are a
mix of human body with the feet of a
horse the Macra be standing nearly twice
as tall as a regular human and the tripe
of women in India who conceive at the
age of five and don't live longer than
eight years and many our extraordinary
creatures are told about but although
these monsters reportedly originated
from the human race they are hardly ever
said to be people who are equipped with
a rationality that is to their strengths
indeed in regards to the Giants who are
counted among these monsters almost no
one doubts that these people were born
from humans and since these creatures
are supported with the authority of
divine scripture we should not commit
them one Lisa Nicole Farley our number
together with these monsters they are
even thought to be sentient certainly if
the things which are read concerning
some Christopher were established seeing
that this well-known rumor about them
spread but although we may think as much
it does not follow that whatever is
produced from a human being is also
human and has been granted with the
genius of human reason for instance it
is read that a calf was born from a lady
or that a serpent emerged from one
concept or take I would agree that
neither the calf nor the serpent had a
human or or rational mind
[Music]